my name is Daniel : Ramos I am an
assistant professor at Yale University
and my lab is interested in
understanding how the architecture of
structures by the brain forms and I you
know I spend most of my time thinking
about these questions but today I wanted
to do a little bit something a little
bit different
and it actually doesn't have to do
directly with research but I wanted to
use the brain and you know some general
musings to basically think about what
what can we learn about the brain with
regards to how we how we learn how we
generate knowledge and also how science
works so what I'm going to be doing
today I'm going to jump it in different
topics and again this is not a science
talk it's more like a general thought
talk but I'm gonna illustrate how how we
think about science and how through
collaborations through creating networks
of knowledge we basically a scientist
generate new knowledge and in that I'm
going to illustrate the importance of
cooperativity and the importance of
collaboration which is a topic that
seldom discussed in the sciences but is
essential for creating an inhalation and
and for furthering designs designs in
general so the brains are made out of
cells that are called neurons and there
are more neurons in a single human brain
than their stars in the whole Milky Way
so there are about a hundred billion
neurons so if there's students out there
that are watching this talk next time
that you're sitting down and looking at
the sky think that they're more neurons
in your brain than their stars that
you've seen in the skies and basically
that so there are a lot of them and they
connect in a very specific way and they
actually underlay human behaviors they
underlay the capacity to communicate for
you to understand this talk and their
organization is critical in that aspect
so we're interested in this question in
how we said that the architecture of the
brain
and my lab in particular pursues this
question by using the nematode C elegans
as a model organism C elegans is a tiny
tiny worm it's about the size of a comma
in a sentence so some of you might be
asking how he said that you can claim to
understand how the human brain which is
so complex works by looking at such a
tiny worm and I wanted to explain a
little bit how we do that because this
is actually how the way that we do it
and the way that all our colleagues in
the field that also use C elegans or use
other model organisms do it actually
highlights how science is done and how
knowledge is generated so C elegans as I
mentioned is really small and the reason
that we use that is because scientists
have created tools that allow us to
examine questions that will otherwise be
very very complicated to examine
questions like how he said that you that
you instruct the architecture of a
structure like the brain and in
particular will you C elegans because
it's the only animal for which we know
the wiring diagram of the whole nervous
system so somebody sat down and mapped
out all of the neurons all of the cells
stuff form part of the nervous system
and so we know who they're connecting to
where they're positioned and for many of
them we know what behaviors they're
important for and all that knowledge is
actually very important because we use
that knowledge to generate and to create
new knowledge so why is that knowledge
important and the reason that knowledge
is important is because of evolution so
it's thanks to evolution that a lot of
the concepts that we find in for example
in C elegans they're actually applicable
to other organisms to other animals
including ourselves and so much so that
in the past ten years six Nobel prizes
have been awarded for people working in
C elegans that have made fundamental
discoveries in C elegans which were then
widely applicable to to two other
systems which further our general
knowledge of how biology works and they
were recognized then with with Nobel
prizes but the important part beyond the
price is that because of evolution we
can use model organisms pH C elegans or
yeast or flies or mice to be able to
generate fundamental knowledge that then
that then can benefit humanity
so that knowledge has told us something
fundamental very important about how the
nervous system works B at C elegans or
our own brains neurons connect to each
other and cooperate to form networks and
that cooperativity between these
individual cells is what basically
underlies the power of the nervous
system the power of our own brain so a
neuron in isolation is is not a powerful
but in combination with other neurons
it's capable of creating all these
circuits which then are are capable of
doing amazing things so I created a
concept of reality and allowing
communication so but one important
aspect is that the number of neurons is
is important but is it more critical
than the number of neurons is how
they're organized so much like having a
bunch of cables does not make a computer
having a bunch of neurons that are
disorganized does not make a nervous
system they have to be organized in a
particular way and again I want to bring
us an example C elegans
C elegans only has 302 neurons so that's
far fewer neurons that 100 billion
neurons that you find in a single human
brain but those 302 neurons are
organized in such a way that allows the
animal to create a representation of its
world to find mates to avoid predators
to find food and that's what we're
interested on we're interested in
understanding how he said that those
neurons get organized and how that
organization then underlies the behavior
of of the nematode the human brain is
obviously organized in a different way
because we don't have the same pressures
the same evolutionary pressures are the
same needs a C elegans so we are our
brains are wired in a different way than
the C elegans brain thankfully and one
of critical aspect of our brain which is
fascinating at least to me is that our
brains are actually wired to be wired
and what I mean by that is that you know
why C elegans is born or when reptiles
are born they know what to do there
they're almost like their behaviors are
wired and they know where to go but when
we're born when a new baby is born it's
actually
it's it looks like at Aristotle used to
call it a tabula rasa it looks like like
the mind is empty it's not really empty
it's wired it's wired to achieve
something very important and that
something very important is to connect
to other humans and to learn from other
humans that's what we are connected to
and that that capacity of our brain to
connect to other people to be able to
learn from others to be able to build on
knowledge that was generated by others
before us is fundamental for the
sciences so knowledge to a certain
extent can be considered a network of
networks because our brain is a network
and then knowledge that we're generating
by connecting our brains to other people
is a network of networks so let me give
you an example of how this works in the
real science world so I became
interested in understanding how the
nervous system of the nematode develops
in embryos but I didn't have the tools
to be able to do that so I collaborated
I linked my brain to two other experts
that had tools that were very beneficial
to to my research and my research was
beneficial to theirs
one of them is C Ron Shaw who's Aslan
Caterine he's a computer scientist
turned developmental biologist and he
developed a computer that he trained to
be able to observe basically here you
have a nematode embryo where the nuclei
in T cells the center of the cells are
labeled in green and the computer is
gonna basically visualize this embryos
it's developing and it's gonna keep
track of every single cell and the
lineage of every cell so at any given
time the computer because we for seeing
us we know the lineage of every single
cell in us watch each cell is and what
its gonna become so so you have this
tool on one hand and on the other hand
we also collaborators he see Ron and I
with another scientist he said
microscopist at the nih called harish
rough and hairy developed a microscope
that was much more powerful than any
microscope that existed at the time and
allowed us to image the embryo
continuously and seamlessly for long
periods of time without damage in the
embryo that work was very important and
in combination with these computer tools
allow us to do things that we couldn't
do before so here's the microscope at
work looking
also the development of this embryo but
you can see is happening much faster
because this microscope that Harry
developed is 30 times faster than the
microscopes that we had before so that
all of a sudden by linking our brains we
were able to do more than we could have
each done individually and this is
actually very important because this is
how science is done at all levels even
if you're claiming to be a scientist
that you were completely alone you're
actually you're you're receiving
knowledge from other colleagues that are
actually colleagues that could be
contemporaries or it could be colleagues
that passed away that generated
knowledge before you came along and
you're building on that knowledge so in
that sense science is actually a network
of networks and it's a community where
we're continuously building on other
people's knowledge and in our case here
we were able to then link what's here on
Wall Street what I was doing and what
Harry was doing to then generate videos
like the one that I'm showing you here
of an embryo that is developing in in
real time and you can see the neurons in
green you can see the nuclei in red and
all of a saw and what this embryo starts
moving you can see that we can actually
keep track of the individual cells
because the microscope that Harry
developed is so efficient and so fast
and we can observe neurodevelopmental
events that were previously inaccessible
and in that way answer questions that we
couldn't answer before so I hope that
with these examples I have Illustrated
to you a little bit how science works
how collaborations work the importance
of collaborations in Sciences which is
fundamental but seldom discussed and if
you're interested in these topics and
you want to hear more I invite you to do
a Google search of my last name with
that block I have a blog on this topic
and also a TEDx talk that discusses in
more depth how the importance of basic
research in biomedicine thank you
you